[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today we are going to be
looking at the top 10 facts you probably
didn't know about overlord I have
recently binge watched a whole series up
to the latest episode and I'm hooked so
I thought that while I wait for the next
episode I'd make a video about it for
you guys this is our first Overlord
video on the channel so if you want to
see more Overlord videos make sure to
smash that like button let me know if
you haven't already subscribed and ring
that magical youtube bell to join the
notification guild the most Opie guild
on YouTube I assure you for the many of
you that voted for the next MHA video on
Instagram and Twitter thank you
I will add up the votes today and start
working on a video for the winner
promptly now without further ado let's
get into the Overlord facts fact number
one there are many versions of overlord
overlord started out as a web novel on a
Japanese fan fiction website called
arcadia the author's pen name was
originally Meucci Moochie put it in but
he later changed it to Maru Yama
kugali Maru Yama picked Arcadia at first
because that is where he would read
other web novels but there was an
incident 2011 where people couldn't even
access the site and the very existence
of Arcadia was at risk so Maru Yama
moved overlord to let's become a writer
a Japanese website for aspiring light
novel authors this same web site was
also home to reesy ro and kono Suba
before they became light novels and
eventually anime Maruyama read a lot of
web novels but couldn't find many that
really appealed to him so he decided to
write one he said in an interview that
writing overlord really felt like
writing fanfiction he took things he
found hard to accept in web novels he
was reading and changed it around in his
own way so it would make sense for
instance one of the reasons he made the
Guardians NPCs or non player characters
is because he found it difficult to
believe that a regular Japanese
salaryman could rule with absolute
authority over extremely
loyal servants otherwise afterwards
overlord was acquired and published by
Enterbrain a Japanese publishing company
owned by Kadokawa the first light novel
overload Volume one the undead King was
released in 2012 the light novel series
is illustrated by sobut the manga
adaptation by Satoshi oshio was released
in 2014 and finally in 2015 we got the
overlord anime the anime is adapted
specifically from the Overlord light
novels the to overlord recap movies were
released in theaters in 2017 and they
also included some changes and additions
as you can see there have been many
versions of overlord and it all started
with a guy writing what he considered to
be fan fiction which is crazy to think
about I can't express how happy I am
that the result was an awesome series
like overlord rather than another 50
shades of grey fact number two there are
huge differences between the initial web
novel and the subsequent light novels in
an interview Maruyama said that the main
reason he changed things was because the
light novel was being published and
people would have to pay money for it
because they were paying money he wanted
the light novel version to be enjoyable
even to his fans who had already read
the web novel he wanted these loyal
readers to get new surprises reading the
novel version and oh boy did they ever
get surprised
for instance you guys remember the
swords of darkness from season 1 in the
anime well they were called acts of
Cyclone the initial web novel and Mullen
who is actually not bad al Gama and not
Ines in the original works as a porter
for them moment and the members of the
acts of Cyclone go their separate ways
without anything bad happening so I'm
sure that the readers of the web novel
were shocked by what ends up happening
to the swords of Darkness I know I was
shocked and I didn't even know that they
were fine in the original there are even
bigger changes than that for example
albedo the best girl for many people
watching the anime isn't even a
character in the original web novel by
the way let me know who the best girl in
overlord is in your opinion I look
forward to hearing your thoughts but
back to the shocking fact that albedo
didn't even exist
the web novel instead deme org is the
overseer but even he has changed
significantly his initial appearance was
much more like a conventional devil for
instance he had horns and red skin these
are not all of the changes trust me
there are plenty more but we got to move
on I gotta say though I'm very glad that
we got albedo and that dem he looks as
cool as he does now this version
definitely reminds you of a Lucar I'm
sad about what happened to the swords of
darkness but it only made mines is
revenge all the sweeter fact number
three there was a popularity poll
conducted for overlord i jus goon placed
number one and got almost 40,000 points
by himself which shows just how popular
not only Ines is but how popular
Overlord is in general in second we got
albedo with over 11,000 points crazy to
think that the most popular female
character wasn't even in the original
version
I bet Maruyama is psyched that he added
her now third was not a banal gamma
fourth was evil eye interestingly enough
fifth was shout here and sixth was damn
you the great Pandora's actor even
placed well at ninth despite having
relatively little screen time in the
anime let me know in the comments if any
of these results surprised you and who
you would have voted for fact number
four interestingly enough character
profiles were released where each
character gets a karma level which is
where they're aligned between good and
evil some characters like hamtaro over
here have a neutral alignment and score
a zero for a sense of justice however
someone like save us the butler of Steel
has a great good alignment and a score
of 300 for sense of justice this makes
sense especially considering what we
know about his creator Lord touch me
what may catch you off guard is that
both our hero ions and main heroine
albedo having an extremely evil
alignment and score on negative 504
sense of justice which is the most evil
score I could find this is one of the
things I find really interesting about
this show our protagonists would often
be considered the bad guys and other
shows it's kind of like Skell
ah God super Opie and got his own show
however although Ines is okay with
killing and no st. by any means
Maru Yama has defended him in an
interview he also calls eyes and the
others an evil army but he stresses the
fact that they can't be labeled
completely evil he says and I quote the
world of overlord operates on the law of
the jungle
so I write as if the strong are good and
the weak are bad while some may view
their actions as evil they act on their
perception of good for example you would
be confused if someone said you're evil
for stepping on an ant write and quote
so there is a more complicated morality
system at play in the world of overlord
this is illustrated beautifully during
the beginning of season 2 when we are
following the perspective of the lizard
people who are being harassed and some
killed because of ions as orders let me
know what you think is Ines evil or is
he just a higher being who should not be
held responsible for killing lower
life-forms all I know is that the
combination of an overpowered and
arguably a moral protagonist has
definitely made for an interesting story
so far fact number 5 in an interview
Mariama has suggested that he's already
more than halfway done the story of
overlord so far there are 13 volumes of
the Overlord light novel series that
have been released
Mariama says that in his head he has
enough ideas to write 50 volumes but he
doesn't plan to write 50 rather he
suggested that the story of Overlord is
probably gonna be closer to 20 volumes
while 30 volumes worth of the story will
be cut out of it he said even up to this
point he had plenty of things he thought
out but then actually right since it is
his belief that it's not good to make a
story too big either that would mean
that over 60% of the story has already
been written if you were to go up to 20
volumes that could possibly mean about
four more 13-episode anime seasons after
this one since one season is usually
made up of three light novel volumes
still though writers including manga is
often underestimate how long it will
take to finish a story so there's still
hope that will get even more overlord
plus with 13 volumes out they already
got enough material for season 4 so we
might not have to
wait that long after season three four
more since I personally just got into
the series I selfishly hoped that it
will be going on for a long time to come
fact number six
motoyama was asked about what he would
write out there Overlord and he said he
would want to write something the exact
opposite of overlord like a modern
school romance comedy with a lot of
girls and he says he even wants to write
about pro wrestling as well although he
hasn't thought it out too much
having just finished my last and longest
research paper for graduate school
myself I gotta say I totally understand
how he feels when he says he wants to do
something completely different when he's
done with his project nevertheless I
hope that it will be a good while before
the great is gone must move aside to
make room for a rom-com about high
school girls or even a pro wrestler
although the latter might be kind of
cool if we're being honest I definitely
check them both out since I love
Maruyama sense of humor fact number
seven Badr Yama the creator of overlord
is shrouded in mystery although some
creators don't like to show their face
and sometimes we're cool super villain
masks - interviews I'm looking at you
horikoshi Maruyama takes it to another
level
there is no pictures of him online so
you can imagine that people were hyped
when they heard he was going to be
coming to Anime Expo in 2018 and they'd
finally get to see him however according
to an anime news network article he
remained hidden behind the black hood
and a Halloween skull mask like I know
gone on casual Fridays he even commented
that the LA heat was much too hot even
for a skeleton like myself like always
everything aside from the heat went
according to the Supreme one's plans and
his mysterious aura remained intact fact
number eight Mariama said that one of
the reasons that he started writing was
because his TRP gie tactical
role-playing game group stopped
gathering this was interesting because
this is very similar to how Overlord
starts near the beginning of the show
ein slams his desk on the table because
he's frustrated that his group members
stopped showing up to play because they
got busy
their real lives this scene left a
lasting impression on me I found it
believable
our protagonist simultaneous feelings of
frustration and sadness felt so real I
took a mental note of that and I didn't
think about it again until I came across
this interview where Maruyama explains
that he was in a very similar situation
now it makes sense how Maruyama was able
to convey these emotions so convincingly
because he must have been going through
them at the time he knew exactly what it
felt like to have people move on with
their daily lives without him in this
interview it does not specify what kind
of T RPGs he played with his friends
although according to Marianas bio on my
animated list
he played Dungeons & Dragons with them
but they eventually got too busy to play
with him they say everything happens for
a reason and although it must have been
difficult for Maruyama to deal with at a
time it was in part because his group
disbanded that we got this amazing
series the world like Maruyama works in
mysterious ways
fact number 9 now once more we must
return to the sacred topic of best girl
although Maruyama refuses to answer who
his favorite character is he did answer
who his best girl in overlord at the
Anime Expo Q&A
it wasn't albedo evil eye or even shout
here it was the girl that plays 26th on
the popularity poll none other than a 10
at the golden princess but it is his
reasoning that's the most interesting
part of his answer he picked a tenet
because according to the creator himself
she's the most absolutely messed up in
the head the anime director now Yuki Ito
responded that all the female characters
are completely crazy in some way so they
all have to be best girl for him but man
now I don't know if I should feel good
or bad for clim it's on the one hand the
best girl loves him but on the other
hand that girl is only best girl because
she's the craziest of the crazy I don't
know let me know your thoughts on this
pressing matter fact number 10 the man
who voiced eyes in the Overlord dub is
Chris Guerrero who also voiced inspector
hound in my hero academia Greer
was also at Anime Expo with the creator
and anime director he gets some bonus
points in my book because when asked
what his favorite part of the Overlord
anime was so far he responded the fight
at the end of season one between shout
tear and Ines and I totally agree
the fight was epic especially seeing
Mayans have to use strategy rather than
simply overpowering his opponent as ko
kutis pointed out for the first time I
was in a fight where he according to the
Guardian was fighting against the odds
and the ending was also rewarding the
director of the dubbing process was also
there and agreed with Guerrero and also
mentioned the scene with Clementine in
season 1 when to quote the dubbing
director Ives just gives a nice girl
a nice hug that was definitely another
one of my favorite moments since the
build up - it was so good and it made
the revenge so so satisfying ok so I
feel like as I'm talking about Overlord
my alignment keeps moving more and more
on the evil side so I should probably
start wrapping it up make sure to let me
know what your favorite moment of
overlord was so far in the comments
anyways guys thank you so much for
watching the first video about Overlord
on this channel a truly historic day to
be sure keep in mind that at Anime Expo
motoyama said that while he was excited
for everyone to see the premiere he's
been more excited than anything for
people to see how this the 3rd season
will conclude so you guys can bet this
season's gonna be an epic one if you
enjoyed this video make sure to smash
that like button to let me know if you
haven't hit the subscribe button and
ring that magical Bell to join our Opie
guild feel free to leave suggestions in
the comments for what overlord video you
would like to see next and until next
time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you